like his predecessor the long-awaited
Frozen 2 is ostensibly a movie for
children but lots of grown-ups are
watching it if anything Frozen 2 doubles
down on bits that seem aimed squarely at
adults here's a look at just a few of
the most memorable
the first Frozen film received a fair
amount of criticism for his lack of
diversity the movie's main cast and most
if not all background characters were
white Defenders of the film cited the
apparent setting of medieval Scandinavia
as the reason for the whiteness but that
excuse didn't really hold water as the
film setting of Arendelle is a fictional
Kingdom and Scandinavia is never
mentioned but Disney was clearly paying
attention to the controversy as Frozen 2
is certainly more diverse for starters
there is now a prominent black character
Lieutenant Matthias voiced by Sterling K
Brown is an arundelian soldier who shows
up early in the film and goes on to
appear pretty consistently throughout
then the rather notholdra a clan of
indigenous people who live in an
enchanted forest and are pretty Central
to Frozen 2 story they're based on the
real-life Sami people from Scandinavia
and Disney World with Sami groups in
developing these characters kids aren't
likely to notice the effort that went
into increasing Frozen 2's diversity but
adults will
despite all the attention Elsa's
sexuality receives from fans only Anna
has ever shown any interest in Romance
in Frozen she spends much of the film
pointing after her Suitor Hans then
after he turns out to be the villain she
falls for Kristoff I kiss you
I could I mean I'd like to I may I we me
I mean may we wait what
we may in Frozen 2 it's made clear from
the get-go that Anna is still very much
interested in men or well one man in
particular Anna and Kristoff are very
much a couple they even casually kiss
from time to time which is kind of an
unusual thing to see in a Disney
animated movie but one scene in
particular makes it seem like Anna has
more than kissing on the brain in the
film Anna Kristoff Elsa and Olaf head
elves on an adventure together in a
wagon pulled by Sven the reindeer
Kristoff and Anna ride together in the
front of the wagon while Elsa and Olaf
sit in the back at a certain point in
the journey both Olaf and Elsa doze off
which doesn't go unnoticed by Anna she
points the situation out to Christoph
and suggests of the asks him what he
wants to do before buggering up her lips
kids will think Anna just wanted a
smooch but adults know that a mere
smooch doesn't require privacy or the
added danger of getting caught
anyone who's seen Frozen knows that Olaf
is full of corny jokes kids may love the
snowman's sense of humor while to adults
he can get a little annoying
did Elsa build yeah why do you know
where she is yeah why do you think you
could show us the way yeah why how does
this work ow button Frozen two Olaf
actually manages to sneak in a couple
one-liners that are aimed squarely at
the grown-ups and one of them is
actually pretty morbid there's an old
Aviation joke regarding black boxers so
called black boxes if you're unaware a
flight recorders that are designed to
survive a plane crash in order to help
investigators determine what caused it
the joke goes something like this if the
black box is Crash proof then why don't
they make the whole plane out of the
Black Box Olaf Tells A variation of this
joke in the movie and he does so at the
most inappropriate moment in the film
Elsa and Anna find the Shipwreck that
killed their parents an unspeakably
tragic Discovery upon finding it one of
them declares that there should be a
record on board in a waterproof box as
that was standard procedure Olaf then
instead of consoling his friends and
it's extremely trying time asks quote if
it's waterproof why didn't they make the
whole ship waterproof kids will laugh at
the joke not knowing that it's a
reference to a very old joke about
airplanes and that Olaf as being
extremely insensitive adults meanwhile
may want to see Olaf melt even more than
they already did
one of the film's big reveals comes near
the end when Elsa discovers why
Arendelle and the North oldra had gone
to war in the past it all started
because the king of Arendelle Elsa and
Anna's grandfather was a colonizer who
upon discovering the notholdra secretly
formulated a plan to destroy them why
because they believe in and essentially
worship the magic of the forest these
beliefs differed from his own which
frightened him so he constructed a dam
on the river under the guise of it being
a gift and destroyed their land when
called out on this by the notholdra
leader the king killed him igniting the
battle between the two people Frozen two
stands on a number of issues has been
clear to critics the film presents a
narrative that shows the harm done by
colonialism religious bigotry and
environmental recklessness in the end
the dam must be destroyed to lift the
curse on the forest symbolizing a return
to the Natural order of things as well
as the destruction of a symbol of
Oppression these are heavy themes and
since they're not spelled out in a super
obvious manner kids probably won't
understand the wit of it with any luck
their parents explain it to them
if there's one thing that best sums up
Frozen 2 it's this love thyself the
movie sends Elsa on a journey of
self-discovery to find the meaning in
her life she's been searching for
forever and she ends up finding herself
near the start of the film Elsa hears a
strange siren song that no one else can
hear this eventually leads her to the
Enchanted Forest where she learns that
the four spirits of the forest air Wind
Fire and Earth are in disarray after she
learns that she has the power to tame
the spirits she's told of a mysterious
fit spirit that acts as a bridge between
all the others Elsa Ventures to find
this fifth Spirit the one who's been
calling to her since the start of the
film and she ends up in a temple trying
to chase down the elusive voice when she
reaches the end of the temple she
realizes that not only is she the fifth
Spirit but she is also the one she's
been searching for the film's message of
self-love is an important one no matter
the viewer and no matter their age
everyone needs to love and take care of
themselves and everyone even adults can
use a reminder of that from time to time
even if it's from a cartoon
the strongest character in Encanto is
middle sister Louisa but if this movie
had been made in the 90s that probably
wouldn't have been the case the reason
why is something only adults will notice
when you think about Disney you usually
think of princesses especially when it
comes to Disney's animated films but
unlike the title characters in recent
movies Raya and The Last Dragon Moana
and Frozen Mirabelle isn't even
technically a princess and the Magical
family isn't royalty that fact is
obvious to anyone but what kids may miss
is that even though they don't live in a
castle or sit on Thrones The Magic
granted to the madrigals gives them an
exalted status in their community so
while they may not officially be
considered royalty by acting as their
community's leaders and protectors the
madrigals are the closest thing to it in
fact the madrigals check many of the
boxes for Royal status including a
Birthright to power that's passed down
through the generations and an unspoken
understanding that they should put the
needs of the family ahead of their own
personal desires mayor Bell's lack of a
gift excludes her from some of these
requirements but she grapples with her
own disappointments over being the only
non-magical magical I call it the nut
special special since uh you have no
gift uh thanks ultimately though
mirabelle's determination to help though
she loves is what makes her most like
Disney's other modern non-traditional
princesses given all this it wouldn't be
a surprise to see Maribel join Disney's
Princess lineup sometime soon regardless
of whether or not she's officially
royalty
Sleeping Beauty has Maleficent The
Little Mermaid has Ursula and Frozen has
Hans ever since Disney's first animated
feature Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs
was released in 1937 almost all Disney
animated films have had a noteworthy
antagonist many of those antagonists
have become as revered as their movie's
main characters but in Kanto won't be
adding to the Disney villain ranks there
is no character and in Kanto who could
be considered a typical bad guy sure
Maribel is often at odds with her
seemingly perfect sister Isabella and
abuela Alma discounts and dismisses
Maribel due to her status as the only
Madrigal without a gift but these are
just family squabbles between people who
love each other and want to get along
the real antagonist of Encanto is less
obvious it's the fear that keeps the
madrigals from being honest with one
another and the pressure to fulfill
their obligations that threatens the
magic powering their home so while kids
may not notice the movie lacks a
traditional bad guy many will still be
able to relate to the way their role
within their family families May limit
what parts of themselves they can show
even to the people they love the most
maribel's middle sister Louisa was given
the gift of strength and ever since
she's used her powers to help the
members of the community with all their
heavy lifting whether it's
single-handedly rounding up an escaped
herd of donkeys and carrying them back
to their enclosure or moving the local
church to a more optimal location Louisa
is constantly busy lifting hauling and
fixing for children growing up now the
fact that Louisa is a woman may seem
Perfectly Natural but grown-ups know
that if Encanto had been made by Disney
a few decades ago there's no way this
story is physically strongest character
would have been developed as a woman the
idea might never have even occurred to
the filmmakers or if it had Luisa likely
would have been ridiculed and ostracized
for her strength thankfully today not
only can Louisa be a woman her strength
is taken seriously and accepted as the
gift it is
countless people wear glasses just not
in movies and that's particularly true
when it comes to Disney's animated
movies while glass is wearing kids will
appreciate seeing mirabelle's sport
eyewear on screen and in Kanto what they
may not know is just how rare it is to
see a main character with glasses
leading a Disney film characters with
glasses haven't been part of the
company's features since the beginning
but it's rare that a main character of a
Disney movie has worn them making
Maribel one of the only main characters
with glasses in the Disney animated
Canon that Mirabelle is a young woman
makes her glasses wearing even more
unique in fact if she were to join the
Disney Princess lineup she'd be the only
one with glasses so while mirabelle's
glasses are unusual for a movie
character like her they're also part of
what makes her special and a family full
of special people gift or no gift I am
just as special as the rest of my family
Frozen is one of the most successful
Disney animated films in recent memory
and between the winning performances
touching story and memorable song songs
it's become a cultural Touchstone
consequently adults may find themselves
automatically comparing the Disney
movies that have come after Frozen to
the earlier film especially in Kanto
which has multiple moments with obvious
parallels first when Mirabelle attempts
to patch things up with Isabella in an
effort to save the family's magic she
makes her sister so angry that Isabella
loses her tight grip on her flower
generating powers and creates a prickly
Cactus Isabella is so excited by the
realization that she can use her gift in
less than perfect ways that she sings
what else can I do one of the movie's
most inspiring songs later when abuela
Alma finds Mirabelle after the Madrigal
home collapses the pair have a revealing
conversation that enables abuela to
finally admit she needs to loosen her
grip on her family so all of their lives
can improve the way the moment plays out
including abuela finding Mirabelle and
their reconciliation by a body of water
is reminiscent of the climax of Frozen
where Elsa realizes love is the ant
answer to all of her problems
perhaps the most famous name associated
with Encanto is that of someone whose
voice is never heard on screen
lin-manuel Miranda who not only composed
the movie songs but helped develop its
story adults will recognize Miranda as
the creator of the Broadway hit Hamilton
and while some lucky kids may have seen
the musical in person or caught the
recorded version on Disney plus they may
not know they've already heard Miranda's
work in another Disney animated film
Moana yet while Moana included
showstoppers like how far I'll go that
uphold the Disney film tradition of
accessible moving songs adults will
notice Miranda uses the opportunity
provided by Encanto to take things in a
different direction with several of its
Tunes in particular Miranda employs a
style more like the one he used in
Hamilton in numbers like the family
Madrigal and we don't talk about Bruno
which include fast rhythmic lyrics and
unpack a lot of information in a short
amount of time as well as overlapping
Melodies that blend and harmonize this
approach makes the songs in Encanto a
bit more electrical and less cinematic
the Miranda's evocative lyrics and
catchy song structure ensure the
soundtrack adds joy and color to the
film
and Kanto reveals that the Madrigal
family has a ritual for receiving their
magical gifts on the fifth birthday of
each Madrigal child the whole town
gathers in the family's Courtyard to
watch as the child approaches a door
that has been newly created by the house
for them the child recites some words in
front of the candle that's the source of
the Madrigal magic and then is imbued
with a gift that soon reveals itself
they then open their door unveiling a
new personalized room just for them
that's based on the gift they received
this is demonstrated in the movie when
mirabelle's cousin Antonio is granted
his gift the ability to talk to animals
immediately after Antonio receives his
gift he's approached by a toucan who
asks Antonio a question that only he can
understand when Antonio agrees to the
toucan's proposal a gang of animals
large and small enter the house and run
into Antonio's new room which is a
magical animal Paradise however the
animals that populate Antonio's room and
now accompany him everywhere aren't just
just any animals they're animals that
are native to Colombia in addition to
the toucans they include raccoon-like
kawati Capybaras the world's largest
rodents macaws tapers and a jaguar in
fact the production even made sure the
tapers are specifically Mountain tapers
to match the mountainous terrain of the
area the madrigals call home
as the family member imbued with
physical strength Louisa is perhaps the
most put upon Madrigal while she never
complains her Services seem to be in
constant Demand by the people who live
in the Encanto and when Mirabelle
realizes the constant work may be
getting to her sister Louisa admits to
the stress she's feeling in the song
surface pressure in the course of the
song she references things that are
likely to go over kids heads not only
does she compare herself to a ship
trying to avoid an iceberg a clear
reference to the sinking of the Titanic
there are also two references to Greek
mythology first Louisa wonders if
Hercules ever felt the same weight of
expectation she feels when he went up
against Cerberus the three-headed dog
that guards the underworld in Greek
mythology as she sings the image shows
Louisa taking on Cerberus herself what
she's referring to however is the 12th
flavor of Hercules in which the demigod
fought and subdued the mighty beast in
addition during the song There's an
image of Louisa holding up the globe a
reference to the Titan Atlas who after
failing to win a war against the
Olympian gods was condemned to hold up
the Heavens For Eternity
if there's one thing in Kanto makes
abundantly clear it's that the madrigals
don't talk about Bruno maribel's Uncle
who supposedly left the family however
in the course of the film Maribel
discovers that Bruno hasn't gone as far
as everyone thought for years he's
secretly been living between the walls
of the madrigal's house with only rats
to talk to needless to say his
circumstances have made him a little
eccentric and part of that eccentricity
is shown in the actions he takes to ward
off bad luck when Mirabelle first
encounters Bruno he knocks on the wood
all around him a familiar gesture to
bring good luck that even kids will
probably recognize however Bruno quickly
follows that up by tossing a pinch of
salt over his left shoulder a gesture he
repeats later in the story after
agreeing to use his gift to help
Mirabelle see her future and while kids
may have seen this done before they may
not realize what adults likely will that
throwing salt over one's shoulder is an
obscure bid to drive away bad luck
Bruno's Reliance on these superstitious
gestures speaks to just how nervous and
paranoid he's become during his
isolation from his family
while the story told an Encanto is
universal the filmmakers have also
included many elements that are specific
to Colombia the country where it takes
place one of the most obvious ways they
achieve this is through the use of
yellow butterflies a motif that's
repeated throughout the movie and is a
reference to the work of revered
Colombian writer Gabrielle Garcia
Marquez in particular yellow butterflies
appear in marquez's Beloved novel 100
Years of Solitude where they symbolize
love and conflict and the way the two
can come together a theme that's
important to Encanto as well the
filmmakers also took care to ensure the
architecture costumes landscape dance
and music incorporated into the film are
accurate to Colombia this can be seen in
the traditional costumes worn by the
characters and the texture of the
materials that were created to design
the madrigal's house moreover songwriter
lin-manuel Miranda said he immersed
himself in the music of Colombia so he
could create songs that felt authentic
to the setting he did this by for
example incorporating the accordion into
the film's opening number because of the
instrument's importance to Colombian
music in fact the accordion is so
essential to the music of Colombia
Mirabelle is seen playing it during the
song
Cruella is the story of how the puppy
kidnapping fashionista first introduced
in 101 Dalmatians fell into a life of
villainy the film captures a bygone era
in a chaotic but appealing way which
will suit viewers who understand how
different things used to be these are
the things only adults will notice in
Cruella it's far from the first Disney
movie to do this but adults in the
audience will notice that Cruella slips
in a few grown-up vices for its
characters it's not the first time
Disney has done this 101 Dalmatians
Beauty and the Beast Sleeping Beauty And
The Great Mouse Detective all classic
Disney films each have scenes depicting
the consumption of alcohol also who
could forget the infamously trippy Pink
Elephant Montage from Dumbo after the
pint-sized Pachyderm accidentally
ingests some Hooch throughout Cruella we
see several characters enjoying fancy
cocktails at parties and liquid lunches
alcohol is the only Vice the film sees
fit to include gone is the Sinister
cigarette holder Cruella deville's
animated version carried it would have
made sense to show smoking both for
character consistency and for the
setting smoking was far more common in
the 1970s and is still associated with
the fashion industry to this day Walt
Disney himself was a fan of tobacco a
truth the company has tried to wipe from
history by editing cigarettes out of his
hands in old photos kids probably won't
notice either the presence of alcohol or
the absence of smoking but both of these
things will be more conspicuous to
adults
[Music]
it's a cliche that if there is a parent
in a Disney film they are most likely
not going to see their kids graduation
from Simba's father to lilo's parents
and Bambi's mom if you produce life
within the Disney Universe your odds of
meeting an untimely demise are much
higher than normal it's become such a
Trope that in many parodies of the
Disney formula the fate of the main
character's parents is now a standard
running joke Disney despite its squeaky
clean reputation often also has the
villains in their stories meet their end
and rather sickening fashion from Bill
Sykes being hit by a train in Oliver and
Company to the Hunchback of Notre Dame
Disney has racked up quite the body
count true to form Cruella utilizes its
PG-13 rating and Ops to lean into this
cliche of Parental death with gusto a
young Cruella known then as Estella sees
her mother meet her end during the First
Act of the film we see Estella chased
from a fancy Party by Angry Dalmatians
who end up knocking her poor mother off
a cliff this definitely ranks as one of
the grizzlier ways a Disney character
has been shuffled off the Mortal coil
especially in recent memory
any kids who see Cruella will be in for
an education on a genre of music that
adults are already familiar with punk
rock Punk started breaking into the
mainstream in the mid to late 70s giving
voice to a burgeoning revolution against
the more excessive style of mainstream
music at the time the punk band's
prevalent during this era operated under
a DIY mentality often self-producing and
distributing their music independently
the movement gained Traction in the
United States with the likes of the
Ramones and the United Kingdom with
groups like The Sex Pistols it was
counterculture politically charged and
in your face it's also a key factor in
the plot and style of the film
especially Cruella fighting back against
the upper class through aggressively
charged art the UK's Punk Rock
Revolution serves as the backdrop for
Cruella's rise to prominence and the
film takes full advantage of it visually
Cruella shown in a quickly paced Montage
stages several raucous public reveals of
her Twisted new fashion line she not
only utilizes motorcycles and a garbage
truck but goes as far as to Stage a punk
rock fashion show right outside her Arch
Rivals event the choice to set the film
in such an important era for fashion and
music is a clever one the chaotic nature
of the music and the visuals suits
Cruella and her ever escalating mix of
insanity and theatricality adults are
far more likely to appreciate the Time
Capsule aspect of Cruella and its use of
one of Art's most tumultuous eras
Disney is no stranger to cartoonish
Madness from Maleficent and Sleeping
Beauty to Ursula and the Little Mermaid
Disney has crafted some of Pop culture's
most memorable and watchable villains
although these characters have fans of
all ages truly committed supporters tend
to be adults who often have a deeper
understanding of on-screen evildoers
complex motivations and psychologies
case in point Cruella has two completely
distinct selves adults will understand
how this fractured psyche symbolized by
the half-black half-white color of her
hair impacts Cruella's Behavior that's
alcohol my name's Stella not Cruella
first there's Estella a mildly sassy but
hopelessly klutzy hot mess who's happy
to stay in her Lane then there's her
less relatable side Cruella a flamboyant
chaotically self-obsessed schemer with
grand plans for Mayhem when presented
with the central conflict Estella is
forced behind the curtain while Cruella
takes Center Stage adults will also pick
up on cultural context the dividing
Cruella's personal is in the tradition
of scores of classic stories such as Dr
Jekyll and Mr Hyde fans might also see
Echoes of DC villain Two-Face who like
Cruella has an outward appearance that
reflects an inner duality
the movie's story draws on the fickle
nature of the fashion industry but
Cruella doesn't stop at just the
internal workings of the business the
film also has a bit to say about how
brands use the media to alter public
perception introduced early in the film
is Cruella's childhood friend Anita
darling who in adulthood has become a
journalist immediately recognizing Anita
as her former classmate Cruella is eager
to enter into a unique business
arrangement with her taking advantage of
their connection Cruella coaxes Anita
into giving her forthcoming public
takedown of the baronesses fashion line
a boost in terms of coverage the media
has often been used to shape people's
perspectives and perceptions for the
benefit of those looking to sell a
product this is obviously far from
exclusive to the fashion industry
examples exist in almost every industry
that said it's a particularly important
aspect of fashion and Cruella does a
wickedly good job of showcasing its
utility adults will pick up on the
concepts of brand awareness demographics
and the manner in which the media talks
to Consumers May meanwhile younger kids
will more than likely watch the movie in
Blissful ignorance with regards to these
themes
kids don't perceive fashion the same way
that adults do as it's an industry built
on what's hot versus what's not words
like Reinventing and Trends pop up quite
frequently in the discussion around
fashion and for good reason they are the
backbone of an industry in which
designers depend on their ability to
churn out exciting new looks on a
regular basis in Cruella we see Estella
constantly innovating with bizarre
designs which end up catching the eye of
the baroness this of course results in a
Stella learning just how Cutthroat the
baroness and by extension the entire
fashion industry truly is I'll just have
to destroy hers we have so many people
find her the film has a lot in common
with the Devil Wears Prada another movie
that uses the toxic side of fashion in
its story both films follow an
unpolished rookie working in the
footsteps of a heinously conceited
fashion Mentor in The Devil Wears Prada
the rookie is Anne Hathaway and the
mentor is Meryl Streep and their Dynamic
isn't all that dissimilar to the one
between Cruella and the baroness and
Cruella the major differences between
the two films lie in their tones and
styles execution The Devil Wears Prada
is a more down-to-earth modern narrative
about what happens when you lose sight
of who you really are meanwhile Cruella
is more stylized and has a lot to say
about identity as well as embracing your
inner Dark Side the toxic and Cutthroat
underbelly of the fashion industry plays
a big part in Cruella but it's aimed
squarely at the adults in the audience
it'll fly over the heads of kids who are
only concerned with whether or not their
shoes have velcro laces
ever since it was announced Cruella
Deville would be getting her own movie
the internet has been saturated with
comments labeling the film as a girl
boss Joker since the release of Joker in
2019 any film or show that portrays a
person's steady unraveling into
villainian violence has been compared to
it it's a story that started being told
far earlier than Joker a couple of
earlier examples both involving Joker
co-stars Robert De Niro are taxi driver
and king of comedy still Joaquin
Phoenix's performance earned him an
Oscar so it stands to reason that people
would see Echoes of Joker in movies that
followed in its wake Cruella and Joker
protagonist Arthur Fleck definitely
share some similarities in the way they
are presented in their respective films
both had unpleasant childhoods which
resulted in Grim adulthoods that found
them grappling with instability as well
as unpleasant lines of work additionally
they both have a moment within their
films that can be seen as a sort of
coming out Arthur debuting his Joker
Persona on Murray Franklin's show and
Estella debuting her Cruella Persona at
the baroness's party one visual
similarity the film's share is how as
the main character's mental state begins
to degrade and their world becomes more
chaotic the world around them becomes
more vibrant it's a smart way of
displaying change and one that shows
just how happy both characters are when
they're indulging in their chaotic sides
[Music]
while Raya and the last dragon is a
crowd-pleasing film for viewers of all
ages there are some parts of the film
that younger viewers may miss from
romantic subtext to religious parallels
here are the things only adults notice
in Raya and The Last Dragon
as Raya and The Last Dragon opens we see
Raya riding her giant roly-poly
companion Tuk Tuk through a Barren
Wasteland dotted with human statues as
we learn 500 years before the events of
the movie dragons and humans lived
together peacefully in a paradise called
kumandra but their harmonious way of
life was destroyed when malevolent
Spirits called the droon invaded turning
everyone they touched to Stone the
dragons fought to protect the humans and
finally prevailed over the Drone but all
of the dragons were turned to stone in
the process save the last one sisu who
disappeared it's a beautiful story but
adult viewers are going to realize that
it seems to have glossed over a few
important parts while Raya presents
kumandra as paradise and its people
living in Perfect Harmony sisu later
explains that the Drone were born of
human Discord if that's the case then
kumandra must not have been the idyllic
conflict-free world that Raya made it
out to be
adults will probably not miss that the
story of the dragons that Riot tells at
the beginning of Raya in The Last Dragon
holds a lot of parallels to a religious
creation Story raya's Story begins with
Humanity living in an idyllic World
watched over by benevolent magical
creatures who served as the source of
water and rain and thus all life it is
even implied that the humans worshiped
the dragons in the reverent way they bow
and raise their hands to their foreheads
whenever they're in their presence when
the Drone arrive it's the dragons who
sacrifice themselves in order to give
Humanity another chance and Dragons Who
ultimately return centuries later to
restore the world to its former glory
even during the 500 years that dragons
are gone human civilization and conflict
all centers around vying for the favor
they perceive as being bestowed by the
last bit of dragon magic kids will
likely take it all at face value but for
many adults the religious parallels will
be too strong to miss
when Raya and namari first meet as
children the two instantly Bond over
their shared interest in dragons later
in the film namari acts as an antagonist
until Raya realizes that the key to
defeating the Drone is trust and
literally puts her fate in the mari's
hands by giving her Hearts peace of the
Dragon Gem it's a moving Arc for both
characters and could hold additional
significance from a certain point of
view some adult viewers May notice that
while Raya never gets an explicit love
interest in the film her relationship
with namare hits many of the same beats
often reserved for romantic
relationships the way they meet closely
mirrors Anna and Han's first encounter
in Frozen when Hans is explicitly set up
as on his love interest and their
interactions throughout the film can
easily be interpreted as flirtatious
even raya's voice actor Kelly Marie Tran
sees their relationship as being
potentially romantic she shared in an
interview with Vanity Fair that while
Disney's official stance says nothing
about rya's romantic inclinations I
think if you're a person watching this
movie and you see representation in a
way that feels really real and authentic
to you then it is real enough authentic
when the terrifying drone show up in
kumandra they take the form of smokey
monsters giving off an ominous purple
glow that overtakes people and turns
them into stone yet for most of the
people the Drone transforms into statues
they don't freeze in the position they
were in when the Drone first wrapped
around them rather most of the time the
statues end up standing with their hands
cupped in front of them as if offering
up an invisible gift to a recipient only
they can see while the position of the
people affected by the Drone is never
explicitly addressed in the film their
cupped hands are actually a subtle way
at foreshadowing the eventual solution
that will be found by Raya and her
friends not only does the cupping motion
hint at the involvement of sisu a water
dragon but it also seems to indicate an
action of offering up something
important to someone else this is what
Raya eventually realizes she has to do
putting her trust in the Mari and giving
her the heart tribes fragment of the
Dragon Gem this is also what the dragons
did 500 years before when they gave the
gem to sisu in the first place it turns
out that the only way to defeat the
Drone is with an act of unit and Trust
which the Drone was subtly telling its
victims all along
in the story Riot tells of the history
of commandra after sisu sacrificed
herself the surviving human tribes went
to war with one another over possession
of the Dragon Gem which held the last
remnants of dragon magic however at some
point along the way someone had to have
noticed that sisu's body was missing
unlike the rest of the dragons who had
been turned to stone sisu just vanished
what's more somehow a legend began that
sisu had been washed away down the river
and that her body lay at one of its many
ends this is the story namari tells Raya
early in the movie which turns out to be
true since it leads Raya to find sisu
six years later and yet even though none
of these stories would have existed
without someone having an idea about
sisu's fate and making a record of it it
appears that no one ever thought to go
looking for the heroic Dragon even while
all of the tribes of kumandra were at
each other's throats over the final
scrap of dragon magic it didn't seem to
occur to anyone to seek out the real
live dragon that was very much Within
Reach it seems bizarre that Raya was the
first to go searching for sisu but every
indication points to the conclusion that
she was was kids may not think to ask
why but adults will likely wonder what
kept anyone else from seeking out sisu's
resting place
after Raya locates sisu she is
understandably wary of letting anyone
find out that her travel companion is a
real-life Dragon even after making
friends with young Boon and the
formidable Tong she is reluctant to let
either of them know her friend's true
nature and yet for some reason early in
the film Raya doesn't hesitate before
telling namari that she's found the
dragon sisu unlike Boone and Tong who
understandably don't think twice about a
human named sisu Raya introduces her to
namari in direct response to namari's
question about whether Raya was looking
for the dragon if anyone was going to
realize that raya's human friend sisu
was actually a dragon in Disguise it
should have been namari that she doesn't
is lucky for Raya but you have to wonder
why Raya risked her realizing the truth
in the first place
during raya's visit to Talon tribe to
locate their piece of the Dragon Gem she
comes across a seemingly abandoned baby
only to realize the baby is a con artist
despite their dishonest Beginnings the
baby and her monkey-like companions
throw in their lot with Raya and wind up
being indispensable in the adventure
that follows eventually we learned that
the baby's name is noi and it quickly
becomes clear that she's uniquely
precocious able to both move and think
on the level of someone many times her
age but while Noy mostly serves to
provide comic relief adults will likely
realize the profound tragedy of a baby
who has had to learn the skills of
someone much older and fend for herself
because she lost her entire family in
the real world such a child would have
likely perished if they weren't taken in
by an older caretaker the option to be
adopted by a trio of benevolent sticky
fingered primates wouldn't really exist
in Raya and the last dragon's fantasy
world Noy is able to forge A New Path
for herself as a street smart trickster
and Thief but adults won't be able to
ignore the deep sadness of a small child
forced to grow up too fast because if
she didn't take care of herself no one
would
numerous times throughout Raya and The
Last Dragon characters question Rye's
quest to collect the fragments of the
broken Dragon Gem she's always elusive
in her answers not wanting to give away
the secret that she's located sisu The
Last Dragon and is trying to reassemble
the gem in order to defeat the Drone and
bring back all the people they've locked
in stone raya's fear is that after
centuries of conflict the other tribes
would probably short-sightedly attempt
to seize sisu's power for themselves
rather than work together for the
betterment of all however while raya's
reluctance to reveal the nature of her
quest to anyone else is understandable
why is she the only one hunting gem
pieces in the first place after all the
Catalyst for all of the conflict is that
each of the tribes wanted the original
Dragon Gem for themselves and that after
it was broken they all took whatever
they could get in the hopes of claiming
some of its power rather than everyone
wondering why Raya is collecting gem
pieces isn't the bigger question why no
one else is it seems that rather than
being mystified by her actions the other
tribe leaders should assume that raya's
goal is to amass more power for the
heart tribe kid kids will likely take
the constant questions about Ryan's
motivations and stride but adults will
wonder why no one else thought to do the
exact same thing
at the end of riot and The Last Dragon
after all of the last representatives of
each of the five tribes have given their
Dragon Gem pieces to namari their
combined trust and cooperativeness
revives the Dragon Gem which in turn
erupts with magic wipes out the Drone
and revives all of the people and
Dragons who have been turned to stone
Raya and her companions are reunited
with their lost loved ones and kumandra
is once again restored to the paradise
it once was except it may not actually
be that simple just as Raya probably
glossed over some less than shiny bits
in her account of History the ending of
Raya and The Last Dragon may not be
quite as happily ever after as it
appears it's implied that the Drone are
a part of the world and that although
the people of commandra may drive off
the Drone for a time they're never truly
gone they just go dormant until a new
opportunity arises for them to strike
for the dragons it took 500 years until
the five tribes could come together and
bring them back hopefully it will take
even longer for them to fall apart
enough for the Drone to find their way
back but adults will realize that as
rosy as the ending appears the threat of
the Drone always remains
imagine this a group of gems each imbued
with immense magical power fall into the
wrong hands and as a result vast numbers
of people are supernaturally wiped out
in the blink of an eye half a decade
later a group of survivors come together
determined to locate all of the
scattered gems and use them to bring
back all the people they've lost the
effort involves some tricky Heist work
but despite some bumps along the road
they're finally able to reassemble all
of the gems ultimately through their
teamwork and the heroic sacrifice of
their leader they're able to reverse the
dark magic of the past and bring back
everyone they've lost sound familiar
obviously that's a broad summary of the
plot of Raya and The Last Dragon but
it's also the basic storyline of 2019's
Avengers end game the massive climax to
a decade's worth of Marvel Cinematic
Universe Adventures obviously the two
aren't exactly the same but it's still
hard to ignore the parallels kids may
not notice some of the big picture
similarities but if their parents are
superhero fans they may get a kick out
of just how much overlap there is
everyone loves a good villain and
Disney's baddies are among the most
beloved and feared in all of Cinema but
while they're hideous skulls and evil
plans are more than enough to scare the
kids there are a few aspects to these
villains that only adults will pick up
on
it's hard to forget Ursula the big bad
of 1989's The Little Mermaid with her
particularly deceitful scheme her eel
henchmen and her instantly iconic music
number Poor Unfortunate Souls Ursula has
easily become one of the most distinct
members of the Disney villain Canon but
something else sets Ursula apart from
her fellow Disney baddies and that's her
real life inspiration of all people
Ursula had her design based on the
famous drag queen and actor Divine so
just how did the star of raunchy John
Waters movies like pink flamingos and
multiple Maniacs come to inspire the
villain of a G-rated Disney musical well
animator Rob Minkoff Drew up a design of
Ursula that ended up bearing a strong
resemblance to Divine Little Mermaid
composer Howard Ashman a major fan of
both John Waters and divine strongly
endorse the design Choice Disney's other
animators took further visual influence
from Divine by giving Ursula a hairstyle
similar to the one done by the drag
queen in Pink Flamingos the connection
between the two only grew as Ashman
committed to channeling Devine's Uber
confident Persona into Ursula's
performance during Poor Unfortunate
Souls
The Hunchback of Notre Dame broke down
many barriers in the world of Disney
animation for one thing this 1996
adaptation of Victor Hugo's novel
explicitly tackled the subject of
religion which no other film in the
Studio's Canon has done for another it
gave a truly adult motivation to its
antagonist Claude frollo as in Hugo's
original novel frollo is a studious
Justice Minister who frowns upon
anything sexual in nature however the
character of Esmeralda a person frollo
publicly refers to as disgusting filth
stirs up feelings of passion inside
frollo's heart his internal conflict
over these forbidden emotions becomes so
great that his villain musical number
Hellfire is fixated on him begging for
forgiveness from God for feeling such
intense lust
where other Disney villains are
motivated by greed or Revenge frollo's
crisis is dictated entirely by his
sexuality this is unexpectedly bold
storytelling territory from Disney a
studio that spent the 1990s releasing
more explicit Kitty Fair like this
earthwormy goodness
indeed upon its initial release the Los
Angeles Times reported letters from
parents questioning the movie's darker
material including frollo's internal
conflicts were too adult for a kids
movie nonetheless by daring to give its
villains such a complex and mature
motivation The Hunchback of Notre Dame
was able to solidify itself as one of
the more unique and underrated Disney
animations
over the years everyone from Claude
Reigns to Oscar Isaac has portrayed
Robin Hood's greedy Nemesis Prince John
so when it was time for Disney to take
on the story of Robin Hood it was
inevitable that the filmmakers were
going to create their own unique version
of the character and in Disney's 1973
animated classic John is portrayed as a
cowardly thumb sucking lion voiced by
two-time Academy Award winner Peter
eustanov Disney's Prince John quickly
became one of the most iconic versions
of the character and for obvious reasons
one of the silliest and most cartoonish
too so much so in fact that it can be
easy to forget that Prince John was in
fact a real historical figure long
before the release of Disney's film King
John ruled over England for 17 years
between 1199 and 1216. sadly there's
little historical evidence connecting
Jon and the semi-mythical figure of
Robin Hood in the real world however the
frequently antagonistic depiction of Jon
and pop culture stems from how he has
been commonly regarded as one of
England's worst kings as far as kings go
Jon didn't have a lot going for him he
lost critical lands in France sent
England into Financial ruin and most
famously of all was forced to sign the
Magna Carta after facing a Revolt from
his own Barons Jon quickly cultivated a
toxic reputation amongst contemporaries
one that survives to this day in stories
like Robin Hood so while children will
appreciate Disney's take on Prince John
as a particularly silly entry into the
pantheon of Disney villains the
grown-ups will be more than aware of the
real man who presented an equally real
danger to his own people
unlike most animated Disney movies
Pocahontas is actually based on a true
story however its deviations from
reality have inspired a decent amount of
criticism over the years including the
lack of evidence for there having been a
romantic relationship between John Smith
and Pocahontas and one of the more
significant changes in the movie's plot
can be found in the fate of its villain
John Ratcliffe in Disney's Pocahontas
Ratcliffe is depicted as a gold hungry
Captain who puts his own selfish
interests Above All Else including the
safety of the indigenous Americans and
with his love of money power and
flamboyant fashion sense Radcliffe fits
nicely alongside his fellow Disney
villains unlike most Disney villains
however Radcliffe is based on an actual
person the real Ratcliffe was an early
settler to America who eventually became
the second President of the Jamestown
Colony whereas Pocahontas depicts
Ratcliffe being tied up and taken back
to England to pay for his crimes however
the actual Radcliffe was killed by
powaton Indians of course Pocahontas is
a film more interested in using the
details of America's settlement as a
springboard for its own story rather
than adhering to the specific factual
details of the era and although it's
nice to see a little dash of reality in
a story like this it's probably best not
to go looking to Disney movies for a
historical accuracy
one of the most striking segments in the
1940 film Fantasia is entitled Night on
Bald Mountain set to the piece of music
of the same name the short depicts a
gigantic monstrous being Awakening an
assortment of spirits eventually the
spirits and the beasts are held at Bay
at the sound of the peeling bells and a
chorus of monks singing Ave Maria
though never given a name in Fantasia
itself the beast at the center of Night
on Bald Mountain is named chernabog
adult viewers well-versed in ancient
mythology will recognize chernabog's
name as one derived from the world of
Slavic myths specifically chernabog's
name means black God and he's also known
as the Lord of evil a creature whose
Deeds were too Wicked to be told in
classic mythology
interestingly another ancient being also
seems to have played a part in inspiring
chernabog in Fantasia the host deems
Taylor refers to chernabog as Satan Bald
Mountain according to tradition is the
Gathering Place of Satan and his
followers
though the character is officially named
chernobog design similarities between
Fantasia's chernbog and the traditional
depiction of Satan are apparent
particularly in their horned heads and
while Knight on Bald Mountain turned out
to be a distinctive enough Endeavor to
ensure that chernobog could stand on its
own two demonic feat grown-up viewers
should be able to appreciate the
terrifying nature of chernobog's true
Origins
some Disney villains yearn for world
domination some want revenge others are
motivated by prophecies dictated by
Magic mirrors Cruella Deville however is
one Disney villain who keeps her aims
much simpler all she wants is to take 99
Dalmatian puppies and turn them into a
fur coat and sure the scheme concocted
by 101 Dalmatians puppy fixated
antagonists aren't exactly ripped from
reality but the Disney version of author
Dodie Smith's legendary villain did take
cues from reality through real life
actress Tallulah Bankhead in a 1985
piece for the Los Angeles Times animator
Mark Davis revealed that Tallulah
Bankhead an actress known for playing
intimidating women was one of the key
Inspirations for Designing Cruella
Deville bankhead's influence didn't stop
there though in the same Los Angeles
Times piece Cruella's voice actor Betty
Lou Gerson reflected that in the first
recording session they told me to see
what I could come up with the first
voice I tried sounded a bit like
Tallulah Bankhead everybody said that's
it don't change it clearly Disney's
iconic take on the character of Cruella
Deville owes a massive tip of the hat to
Bankhead and it's nice to know that the
inimitable movie star is still
terrifying kids to this day even if they
have no idea who she is
the 2008 Pixar classic Wally wears its
homages to Classic Cinema on its sleeve
and one of Wally's more explicit
references to the movies can be found in
the principal villain one who film fans
will be sure to recognize Auto may be
designed to look like a steering wheel
but the robot's gigantic glowing red
circle makes it perfectly apparent that
it's supposed to evoke Hal 9000. the
villainous computer from 2001 A Space
Odyssey the two carry similar designs as
well as a shared determination to enact
their own agendas over the well-being of
their human superiors
Auto's connection to 2001 becomes even
more explicit in the climactic showdown
between the captain and auto which
employs the Richard Strauss composition
also sprach zarathustra that Strauss
piece of course was also used to
immensely memorable effect in 2001 A
Space Odyssey Auto does however depart
from how all in one aspect Hal was
voiced by Douglas rain and was meant to
carry a more human quality than even the
movie's Flesh and Blood characters open
the pod bay doors hell
I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do
that
conversely Otto is voiced by Macintosh
Apple's text to voice software this
gives Otto the most lifeless voice out
of all of Wally's cast giving Otto
unique qualities compared to Hal ensures
that this Wall-E villain can work as a
standalone entity for younger viewers
and in the process make the character
more than just a meaningless parody of
2001. the alien antagonist in 2005's
Chicken Little are fluffy teardrop
shaped Critters who look pretty much
tailor-made to be sold at your local
Disney Store however these aliens don't
reveal their true forms until chicken
Little's final moments up until that
point these otherworldly visitors lurk
inside large robots that move around on
Long mechanical legs older viewers of
course will take one look at these
machines and realize they have more than
a passing resemblance to the antagonists
of H.G Wells The War of the Worlds in
Wells seminal work the Alien Invaders
move around in giant machines known as
tripods in the book Wells describes the
tripods as higher than many houses
striding over the young pine trees a
walking engine of glittering metal
striding now across the Heather
articulate ropes of Steel dangling from
it
the same description pretty much matches
chicken Little's own mechanical aliens
this homage proved timely for chicken
little too given that Steven Spielberg's
War of the Worlds also debuted in 2005
placing the tripods firmly back in the
public consciousness
The Lion King's villain scar doesn't
exactly hide the fact that he's evil his
contempt for Simba is palpable in their
earliest conversations and he relishes
the chance to throw his own brother
Mufasa off allege to his death but in
case anyone in the audience doesn't
quite understand the full extent of
Scar's cruelty The Lion King offers up a
few visual cues to cement his nefarious
nature during Scar's big be prepared
musical number the animators of The Lion
King made short a bask Scar and visual
parallels to contemporary Nazi
propaganda Nazi imagery is Rife
throughout the entirety of be prepared
including Scar's hyena henchmen marching
in a goose step formation while scar
looms above them an arrangement echoing
how Adolf Hitler would appear at
military parades and rallies the beams
of light surrounding scar during be
prepared also evoke the lighting devices
used at Nazi rallies thus creating a
very a creepy image of a feline fuhrer
the idea to tie scar into Nazi imagery
came about incidentally through an
animator doodling scar as Hitler this
throwaway picture inspired the visual
team Behind The Lion King to create
nazi-related visual parallels all
throughout the be prepared sequence the
result was a sequence that easily
reaffirmed the character's evil nature
while also creating some of the movie's
most striking imagery
for a Disney film Hercules manages to
slip in quite a few jokes in pop culture
references that could easily go
unnoticed by younger audiences from
Disney Easter eggs to mythological
Origins here's a list of the things only
adults will notice when watching
Disney's Hercules
Greek mythology isn't exactly
kid-friendly there's plenty of death
despair extramarital Affairs drinking
cannibalism and an array of terrifying
monsters that would give most children
nightmares with this in mind it makes
sense that the film had to take
Liberties regarding the actual Legend of
Hercules the film shows Zeus and Hera as
being in a healthy loving relationship
however this couldn't be further from
the case in mythology Zeus has a
reputation for cheating on his wife with
an extensive list of women a fact that
Hera is well aware of and resents about
her husband Hercules isn't even Hera's
son according to mythology in fact
Hercules wasn't born to two Divine
parents instead he's the child of Zeus
and the Mortal woman elkmina the main
reason this change was made in the film
is likely because Hera is behind
Hercules hardships in the original story
not Hades like in the movie Hera resents
Hercules and as a result tries to have
him killed additionally megura is most
likely a combination of two characters
from mythology megura and Hercules
second wife dianira in a grim turn of
events Hercules actually kills megura in
the original myth so much for happily
ever after in Hercules the city of
Thieves otherwise known as the big Olive
is a major Metropolis known for its high
energy and hustle and bustle basically
Thebes is one giant New York stereotype
from the pita bread carts to the
Doomsday graffiti smeared around the
city walls thieves reflects many aspects
of the Big Apple itself for better and
For Worse much like New York Thebes and
all of its inhabitants are always in
motion there are chariots blazing back
and forth while pedestrians wait at what
appear to be ancient crosswalks large
crowds abound and Hercules is clearly
overwhelmed by the city environment when
Hercules and Company first arrived they
nearly find themselves trampled by a
chariot driver only to be saved by Phil
who's more seasoned in navigating The
Hectic City enraged by the rude driver
the Seder yells hey I'm walking yes
a typical New Yorker accent along with
the reference to the Manhattan set movie
Midnight Cowboy further cements the
connection to Modern New York much like
New York Thebes also has a bit of a
Shady Side as well like Hercules who's
never set foot in a big city before at
one point the gang is approached by a
man in an oversized trench coat who at
first glance seems to flash the
unsuspecting group however this is a
Disney flick so the Flasher is actually
just a sundial salesman with his stock
hidden beneath his coat in one scene
Hercules is seen wearing a lion skin for
many viewers this wouldn't raise any
eyebrows especially since the lion is
likely a nod to the neemian lion the
first of the 12 labors that Hercules had
to face in the original mythology
however more seasoned Disney fans May
notice something a little too familiar
about the Ferocious feline from the
uniquely brown fur and black Mane to the
scar under the big cat's eye the lion
looks exactly like scar from The Lion
King
he'd make a very handsome throw rug
overall it's a bit uncomfortable to see
Hercules and Phil thoughtlessly parading
around the lifeless body of another
Disney character on screen while this is
undoubtedly a clever nod to another
popular Disney title the implications
are rather dark in this universe scar
was killed and then skinned for his fur
coat which is definitely a morbid end
for the recognizable Villain at the
beginning of the film all of the gods
and goddesses gather at Mount Olympus to
celebrate the birth of Zeus and Hera's
newborn son Hercules the various deities
are lounging around talking drinking
from fancy glasses and enjoying each
other's company as the crowd partakes in
the joyous celebration Hermes Zips
through the scene and comments to Zeus
I haven't seen this much love in a room
since narcissus discovered himself
this joke is a nod to the Greek myth
Narcissus
narcissus was a man of unparalleled
Beauty who spurned the advances of the
nymph Echo this earned Narcissus the
Wrath of the Gods who made the man fall
in love with his own reflection as he
gazed into a pool of water narcissists
unable to have his obsessive love with
himself reciprocated eventually died of
starvation as he stared at his
reflection
after his date with Meg Hercules Raves
about the play the pair just saw that
play that Oedipus thing then I thought I
had problems the pair must have seen a
performance of Sophocles edipus Rex an
Athenian tragedy you wouldn't expect to
pop up in a Disney title in the play
Oedipus unknowingly kills his father
King Elias and becomes the king of
Thebes
aside from killing his own father once
crowned King Oedipus unknowingly marries
his mother and fathers several children
considering the dark themes and Oedipus
Rex it's definitely a strange title to
be referenced in a children's animated
film Meg is beloved for her sassy
attitude and Sly remarks that set her
apart from many Disney leading ladies
however what actually makes Meg Stand
Out Among the Disney Princesses isn't
just her Saucy personality but her
experiences in the dating Arena Disney
loves to focus on Happily Ever After
endings and as a result many Disney
characters have optimistic and slightly
naive views of love this is mainly
because prior to their love interest in
their respective film they haven't dated
at all Meg on the other hand hasn't only
dated other men before Hercules she's
been outwardly betrayed by the man she
loved at the cost of her own freedom as
a result Meg has a far more realistic
and at times pessimistic view of love
and Men a prime example of this is after
Hercules saves her from nessus she tells
him well you know how men are they think
no means yes and get lost means take me
I'm yours it's because of her negative
experiences that Meg has trouble warming
up to Hercules her entire song I Won't
Say I'm in Love shows her struggling to
embrace her feelings without losing her
common sense and falling prey to another
bad relationship for a Disney lead Meg
is undoubtedly a far cry from the
typical doe eyed Adventure seeker and
that's why she's still so popular to
this day
in the film Hercules the muses are the
film's narrators that guide viewers
through the narrative their songs also
allow for a natural passage of time
between significant events in the film
using the muses as narrators is a smart
modern adaption of the Goddess from
mythology who presided over the Arts
but aside from this adaptation of the
characters there's another connection to
ancient Greek Theater ancient Greek
Theater would have looked very different
from a production of the Phantom of the
Opera one of the most significant
differences in the structure was in how
the characters were written in addition
to having roles for the main characters
ancient Greek Theater also frequently
employed a group of actors to serve as
on-stage narrators this group was the
chorus and they usually had one member
who was the chorus leader so to have the
gospel style course of singers also
occupy the role of the Greek course in
this film is an interesting blend of
both mythology and ancient Greek
entertainment after the fates prophesy
that Hercules will destroy Hades plans
of overthrowing Zeus Hades realizes that
for his evil plan to take flight he'll
have to kill baby Hercules he then sends
pain and panic his two bumbling
sidekicks who almost immediately botched
the entire operation instead of having
Hercules ingest the entire bottle of
poison they were given they mess up
turning him mortal instead so then what
to pain and panic do they leave Hercules
for two mortal humans to raise
even worse they neglect to tell Hades
that Hercules isn't dead
so imagine Haiti's surprise when he
finds Hercules grown up and saving
damsels in the woods but really Hades
can't place all of the blame on pain and
panic it's confusing as to why Hades
left such an essential task to his
minions in the first place more
confusing is why he never even bothered
to verify that the job was completed
presumably he can see for himself each
soul that enters the underworld without
having to leave the comfort of Home
shouldn't he have been on standby to
make sure pain and panic didn't mess
things up this is pretty lazy behavior
from someone who wants to become the
king of Mount Olympus
the allusions to Modern Life in Hercules
show that life in ancient Greece wasn't
so different from life today well at
least in Disney's version of ancient
Greece anyway for example as a New Soul
enters Hades realm there's a number
counter that says over 5 billion one
served mimicking McDonald's which
proudly advertised billions and billions
served that's one of the earliest modern
references in the film but it surely
isn't the last later when pain and panic
are pretending to be children trapped
under a boulder in an obvious parallel
to 9-1-1 one of them shouts
[Music]
one of the best places to find these
modern references is during the film's
musical numbers during Phil's song one
last hope there's a training montage
where Phil Hercules and Pegasus are all
standing on pillars training in front of
a sunset this is a callback to the
training montage in the Karate Kid there
are also a ton of references in the song
Zero to Hero one of the more fleeting
examples is when the movie shows the
line outside of Hercules store and we
see two shops located on either side of
the building these stores are named
Aphrodite's secret and column and Barrel
alluding to Victoria's Secret and
Creighton Barrel respectively
the song also features more nods to the
modern day such as the Grecian Express
card the air herc sandals and the
Hercule drink
the film's most prominent and easily
recognizable reference to real world art
is likely the Venus de Milo from which
Hercules removed the arms while on his
date with Meg but sharp-eyed viewers
will find multiple examples of classical
art and architecture scattered
throughout before Hercules begins his
journey he has an incident at the Agora
resulting in its destruction though the
construction is slightly different the
architecture Bears a striking
resemblance to Saint Peter's Square in
Rome after this socially traumatizing
incident Hercules talks to his adoptive
parents where another bit of ancient art
can be found looking at the interior
design of their home the wall design
looks like Acro tiri spring Fresco or is
at least partly inspired by it another
example of ancient architecture can be
seen in Go the Distance as Hercules
enters the Temple of Zeus sitting tall
is a colossal Stone likeness of the
Thunder God which comes to life to tell
his son about the necessity of becoming
a true hero the actual Temple used to
house a reasonably similar statue though
the historical monument was accented
with a gold staff not seen in the film
finally the last easily recognizable art
reference appears during the song I
Won't Say I'm in Love when Meg walks
past the muses standing as pillars in
reference to the Cary addits of The
Acropolis while the real carry addits
are grander in scale they certainly lack
a similar musicality
1995's Toy Story is arguably Pixar's
most beloved film for both kids and
adults kicking off his sprawling
franchise that's endured the test of
time as much as kids might love seeing
their favorite toys have Adventures
however re-watching Toy Story as a
grown-up reveals the film as a dense
sometimes dark movie with more layers
than one could have ever imagined as a
little kid animators filled Toy Story
with subtle gags Easter eggs and
cultural references that very few
children would understand but that their
parents and even grandparents might get
a kick out of for example the character
of Mr Potato Head is voiced by the late
great insult comedian Don Rickles who is
at the height of his career and stand up
in the 60s and 70s at one point Mr
Potato Head makes a crack at one of
Andy's other toys you one cultured swine
what are you looking at now hockey puck
referring to someone as a hockey puck
which definitely sounds like something
you can't say on TV was rickle's
signature line on the other end of the
spectrum is a super creepy carpet in
Sid's house how can a carpet be creepy
because it's the same pattern as the
carpet of the nightmarish Overlook Hotel
in the 1980 horror classic The Shining
where we saw Dany playing with his toys
come and play with Woody and Buzz
forever
something very intimate is definitely
going on between Woody and Bo Peep And
while kids might take their
conversations at face value adults in
the know recognize it as pretty
suggestive what do you say I get someone
else to watch the Sheep tonight hell
yeah I
what exactly they're going to do is Up
For Debate given traditional toy Anatomy
but there's no doubt about what's going
on here Bo Peep is pre-arranging a booty
call another risque joke requires a bit
more unpacking one of Sid's freaky
Franken toys is named legs and she
consists of what appears to be the long
shapely legs of a Barbie doll connected
with a hook on a line in other words
legs is a hooker Woody is a kind cowboy
in the vein of classic good guy cow
pokes like Roy Rogers and Gene Autry one
thing that sets him apart is that
although he's the hero of the movie
Woody makes a lot of attempts to get rid
of his new rival permanently Woody moves
to get rid of perceived interloper Buzz
Lightyear intending to knock him behind
a piece of furniture so he'll get lost
he instead knocks him out of an open
window where there is little chance
he'll ever be found even worse he grabs
the remote of RC the remote controlled
car and forces that toy to be the one to
nudge Buzz thereby making RC an
unwilling accomplice usually in Disney
movies it's the bad guy who tries to
kill the good guy in Toy Story the good
good guy tries to kill the other good
guy Toy Story is a movie for kids but
some of its themes are much more
familiar to adults particularly those
who struggle with mental illness at its
core it's a movie about anxiety
delusions and the disappointment of
believing you're not living up to your
potential for the first half of the film
Buzz Lightyear believes that he's not
just a toy but that he really is an
actual Space Ranger
he is so firmly under that delusion that
he cannot see his reality for what it is
he hangs around self-aware toys and
lives in a child's room and even freezes
when real humans come around but still
does not waver in a stance the only
thing that makes Buzz realize what he
truly is comes when he sees a TV
commercial for Buzz Lightyear toys and
in it sees rows and rows of himself on a
toy store shelf Buzz immediately and
understandably becomes quite depressed
also dealing with an identity crisis is
Woody the film's other main character
his main motivation for getting rid of
Buzz is to remain the dominant toy in
Andy's heart and Toy Box an
old-fashioned toy he is extremely
threatened by the shiny high-tech Buzz
Lightyear toy swooping in and stealing
his plays is Andy's favorite he's like a
cowboy doll version of Willie Lowman
from Death of a Salesman desperately
trying to hold on to relevance and
usefulness in a changing world that
finds him increasingly obsolete the toys
of Toy Story are living things of course
because they clearly walk talk think and
feel but that isn't the same as being an
actual biological organism the main
difference between the toys and animals
for example is that they cannot die in a
normal fashion they are simply played
with or not played with if they are
played with great if not they sit on a
shelf or in a toy box or some other
storage option indefinitely aware of the
passage of time as they remain they wait
and wait and wait to be played with a
moment which may never come we
definitely know that toys can die though
since Sid blows up a combat Carl action
figure and Buzz nearly meets his end in
a similar way as Sid ties a small rocket
to his back even worse sits homemade
chimeras are also alive Frankenstein
together from other dismembered toys so
toys can die but the only means by which
to kill them is with brutal painful
torture and even that might not end
their suffering now that's dark
Disney's Peter Pan has been loved by
families for Generations unfortunately
this animated classic hasn't aged
entirely well over the years much of
this goes over kids heads but older
viewers might be surprised by some
scenes for good or bad here are things
that only adults notice in Peter Pan
as a child it feels perfectly innocent
to fantasize about some magical being
coming to your window to take you away
on adventures in Far Away lands as an
adult however the thought of strange
boys visiting underage daughters via
bedroom windows is much less Charming
when Wendy claims Peter Pan has been to
the nursery before and must surely be
coming again because she'd found his
shadow her mother seems a bit perplexed
her father on the other hand brushes it
off as childish Fiddle Faddle and mocks
his wife's concern
gracious whatever shall we do however
had the same conversation been with more
literal or protective Guardians Peter
likely would have found a father waiting
with his shotgun in that Nursery instead
of a pining unattended Wendy at the very
least it would have been wise to leave
the family dog Nana in the house with
the kids rather than tied up outside on
top of that the grown mind can't help
but question Mr and Mrs darling's
decision to leave their young children
home alone for hours without any sort of
adult supervision if you're not going to
have your dog protect your children
while you're out partying at least find
a human to babysit
fairies are some of the most iconic
creatures in the worlds of fantasy but
their disposition varies widely between
sources in some instances they're
benevolent and wise like Cinderella's
fairy godmother while other portrayals
of the magical beings show a much darker
and malevolent nature Peter Pan's
sidekick Tinkerbell seems to lie
somewhere in the middle tank displays a
mean jealous streak the moment she
learns Wendy will be accompanying them
back to Neverland going so far as to
make an attempt on her life without
Peter's knowledge
after abandoning Wendy while flying to
Peter's Hideout Hangman's Tree
Tinkerbell tells the awaiting lost boys
that he gave orders to shoot down a
terrible Wendy bird spotted in the skies
sadly the Lost Boys Follow Tinker Bell's
instructions and attack her but Peter
manages to fly over just in time to save
Wendy from crashing down onto the jagged
rocks below when Peter asks Tinkerbell
if she's guilty or not guilty of
attempting to get Wendy shot down she
has an honest and disturbing response
guilty but don't you know you might have
killed her
after being banished for her malicious
plot Tink makes things even worse by
turning on Peter disclosing his Hideout
to his arch nemesis Captain Hook
thankfully she redeems herself in the
end by Saving Peter from a bomb that
hook disguises as a gift but still it
doesn't excuse tink's attempt to plant
Wendy's Six Feet Under
being a child forever sounds pretty
liberating on the surface but when
examined more deeply it definitely has a
dark side while infantile Behavior
brings Carefree fun and spontaneity it
can also cultivate a short-sighted and
selfish nature this is exhibited Time
and Time Again by Peter Pan who
repeatedly puts others in danger thanks
to his immature actions and motives from
the moment he's introduced he constantly
makes everything about himself as a kid
it's easy to mistake Peter's decision to
take Wendy and her brothers to Neverland
as a form of Liberation and a heroic
rescue from growing up which George
tells Wendy she'll have to do starting
the next day by moving out of the
nursery with her brothers and into her
own room however more mature viewers are
apt to note that Peter only invites them
to Neverland because Wendy's imminent
relocation would put an end to her
adventure stories and Peter truly loves
these Tales because they're about him
but the character's dark side doesn't
stop there Peter also treats all the
females in his life like trinkets rather
than people quickly moving on to the
next shiny thing in front front of him
like when he leaves Wendy behind for
Tiger Lily to top it off he occasionally
drops misogynistic insights and demands
that haven't aged well at all girls talk
too much
talk to him
oh well get on with it girl my name is
Wendy when watching Peter Pan adult
viewers can't help but notice disturbing
levels of racism in the classic film
it's so bad that Disney plus even added
a disclaimer before the film warning
viewers about quote negative depictions
and or mistreatment of people or
cultures not only does this film depict
Native Americans in horrifically
prejudiced ways the movie is carpet
bombed with racist slurs against them
everyone from innocent children in the
heroic pan to the villainous Captain
Hook casually speak of them as Savages
and much worse the poor treatment of
Native Americans and other First Nations
people culminates in a sing-along titled
what makes the Red Man red which is
loaded with cultural appropriation and
racist stereotypes
early in the film we learned that
Captain Hook has a perfectly viable
reason for being so upset with Peter Pan
after all he's responsible for hook
having a hook in the first place during
a skirmish with the villain Peter cut
off Hook's hand and fed it to a nearby
crocodile who then developed a taste for
the pirate Leader's flesh as a result
the crocodile constantly haunts Captain
Hook and follows him around Neverland
hoping for another nibble luckily the
crocodile also swallowed a clock so he
can be easily detected by the
distinctive sound of ticking emanating
from his tummy Hook's encounters with
the crocodile make for some of the
funniest moments in the film but it also
stirs up some questions within the
Discerning adult mind
specifically one can't help but wonder
why hook doesn't just organize a group
of his men to execute the Beast so he no
longer has to live in Perpetual fear
he's a badass pirate captain in charge
of a ship loaded with dangerous men
cannons and other weapons he should put
those to good use against the crocodile
so he can move on with his life plus the
Croc doesn't seem to be too elusive or
quick moving however like most kids
adults should overlook this leap in
logic and enjoy the Timeless comedy of
these two fighting it out
an uncomfortable aspect of Peter Pan
comes into focus when analyzing the
questionable relationship between Peter
and Wendy the two technically meet for
the first time after he breaks into the
nursery window at night while her
parents are out which is unnerving
enough however Peter had to have been
there at least once before while she was
sleeping considering Wendy found his
misplaced shadow in the nursery which
definitely amps up the creep Factor then
things get even more uncomfortable while
considering the weighty decision of
whether she should go with a stranger to
a Strange Land Wendy wonders aloud what
her mother will think Peter being unwise
in the ways of the world asks Wendy what
a mother is to which she replies a
mother someone who who loves and cares
for you and then tells you stories good
you can be our mother moments after this
statement Wendy declares she's so
excited to see Peter that she's going to
give him a kiss and not in the motherly
sort of way this has some weird Freudian
connotations to say the least and it
sets a bit of an odd undertone between
the two throughout the rest of of the
film
in the latter half of the movie Wendy
sings A touching song called your mother
and mine it's a sweet melody praising
motherly love soothing enough to lull
her Rowdy brothers and the Lost Boys
into a relaxed Blissful State Wendy's
song even brings the Pirates to tears
one pirate in particular Mr schmee
Captain Hook's comical boson is shown
crying while pulling up his shirt to
reveal a classic mom tattoo on his chest
making this one of the films more
memorable and humorous moments even
tough guys love their mamas and when
watching this scene as an adult it
genuinely pulls on the heartstrings and
makes shmee's actions far more relatable
as a kid it's easy to take songs about
mothers for granted but once you've
moved out on your own your mom isn't as
easily accessible and distance makes the
heart grow fonder more than a few adults
watching this movie probably found
themselves getting mistied during this
touching tribute to mothers everywhere
they say you should never meet your
Heroes and for those who idolize
mermaids this is particularly true while
watching Peter Pan mermaids are
generally depicted as friendly
benevolent creatures especially in such
films as Splash or The Little Mermaid
however Neverland's resident merfolk
have darker Natures which Wendy learns
to her detriment while exploring the
island with Peter as it turns out Peter
is quite the Ladies Man and Wendy finds
herself vying for his attention while he
catches up with fangirling mermaids in a
Neverland Lagoon once they notice Wendy
however the mermaids switch from
flirtatious Vixens to jealous tyrants
while Peter looks on laughing the
mermaids attempt to pull her under the
water
this is the second time Wendy nearly
meets her fate at the hands of one of
Peter's female friends and like
Tinkerbell the mermaids own up to their
true intentions in sociopathic like
fashion the mermaids acknowledge exactly
what they were trying to do we were only
trying to drown her
after losing his temper early in the
film George darling takes his
frustrations out on Nana the canine
Nanny by Vanishing the poor dog outside
to her lonely drafty dog house it's
sadly ironic as she's the least chaotic
and most helpful member of the entire
family this is extra cruel considering
she's not just any dog Nana thinks of
herself as a nursemaid and that she
belongs inside watching over the
children she does all the things a
traditional caretaker would modifying
some activities to accommodate her lack
of opposable thumbs it's hard not to
Marvel at her incredible dexterity and
ability to carry out a multitude of
domestic tasks even professionally
trained dogs could learn a thing or two
from Nana's extensive skill set and yet
the darling family seems to take her
entirely for granted for example while
George is angrily pacing about making a
scene over his outfit Nana continually
tries to clean up and care for the kids
in the background Nana is so loyal that
when George struggles to find the Rope
to tie her up outside pauses
mid-banishment to find it for him while
she's just another humorous character
for kids to enjoy many adults watching
the film probably wish they could have
their own Nana around the house
although some of Peter Pan's content
hasn't aged too well one of its spin-off
movies more than stands the test of time
directed by Steven Spielberg 1991's hook
imagines a life where Peter falls in
love with Wendy's granddaughter Moira
and leaves Neverland to start a family
of his own it's a heartwarming fantasy
featuring a stellar cast including Robin
Williams as Peter Pan Dustin Hoffman as
Captain Hook and Julia Roberts as
Tinkerbell ironically the once Carefree
boy grows into an incredibly
stiff-necked workaholic with a fear of
heights
he's also too busy climbing the
corporate ladder to spend any quality
time with his kids but daily life is
interrupted for Peter's family when
Captain Hook kidnaps his children and
takes them back to Neverland Peter is
forced to face his past in order to save
his family's future in the process he
remembers what's truly important in life
reconnects with his inner child and
finds Redemption with his loved ones
It's a grand adventure exploring a
boldly reimagined Neverland but it's
also loaded with fun callbacks to the
1953 classic granted critics weren't
especially fond of it when it first hit
theaters but nevertheless Hook is a
joyous family-friendly ride plus the
special effects still hold up the
musical score is excellent and best of
all the movie doesn't contain any of the
outdated and cringy moments that only
adults would notice from the original
animated version
kids love a Disney princess and who can
blame them they're kind they're caring
and they're usually pretty badass too if
you're a grown-up however you might
notice a whole different side to these
iconic movie characters here are some
things only adults notice about Disney
princesses
it's not all that easy pinning down
Beauty and the beast's time frame the
movie falls into that generic
post-medieval era to which so many other
fairy tales belong you know the kind of
time where the gowns all have hoop
skirts but where there aren't so many
nights and shining armor around however
Luke Evans who plays Gaston in 2017's
Beauty and the Beast narrowed the era
down considerably in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly saying when Gaston
was about 16 he protected the town from
a pack of Portuguese Marauders in 1740
based on this assertion you can safely
assume that Beauty and the Beast takes
place in the 1750s perhaps as late as
1760 and sure the reign of Louis XV
serves as a good backdrop for this
beloved romance until you remember what
happened a couple of decades later yes
it seems likely that Belle and the Beast
are going to find themselves in a spot
of bother once the French Revolution
comes around in 1789. luckily their
grizzly bait isn't quite set in stone in
2020 Disney launched the Queen's Council
a new line of historical novels that
intertwined their heroine stories with
actual historical events and sure enough
Rebel Rose the first book in the series
finds Belle living in 1789. she's just
freed the beast from his spell but the
revolution is coming to town and she
soon finds herself torn between her
Roots as a commoner and her future as a
royal sounds like she better start
teaching Lumiere the words to La
Marseilles
kids will be easily swept up in
Pocahontas tale of conflict Harmony and
sentient will of trees but adults will
likely be aware of just how much
Disney's version differs from the actual
story so what are the biggest
differences between real life and the
Silver Screen well firstly the woman
known as Pocahontas wasn't actually
called Pocahontas she was named amanut
and sometimes also known as madawaka
Pocahontas was a nickname meaning little
wonton which she garnered for her
mischievous nature little is the key
word there of course because Pocahontas
certainly was little in fact she was
roughly 11 or 12 when she rescued John
Smith even the veracity of that rescue
is in doubt however as some historians
suggest Smith lifted the tail entirely
from a popular ballad Pocahontas was
later kidnapped by an English colonist
and used as a bargaining chip during the
first anglo-powhatan war she was
eventually taken to another English
settlement where she converted to
Christianity took the name Rebecca and
accepted a marriage proposal from a man
named John Rolfe though this marriage
led to a truce known as the Peace of
Pocahontas the woman herself died in
England only a handful of years after
her marriage at the age of 21. Disney
isn't the first to co-op Pocahontas for
their own purposes and they won't be the
last but that doesn't change the Awful
Truth behind her real life story
Mulan has got to be one of the most
courageous Disney princesses of all
despite her lack of training her
insecurities and the limitations placed
on her because of her gender Mulan goes
to war in her father's place Luckily
everything turns out pretty much okay
she Saves the Day wins the war and
reunites with her father not every
version of mulan's tale and so well
however if you're familiar with the
ancient folk stories that inspired Mulan
you'll know that her story has carried
all kinds of moral lessons over the
years including a few that aren't
exactly family friendly for example
churrenjo author of The Late 17th
century Romance of Sway and Tang depicts
Mulan as a virtuous Warrior one who
becomes a sworn sister to the benign
princess shenya tragically the respect
she earns while posing as a man pretty
much vanishes when it's revealed that
she's actually a woman rather than be
forced into concubineage Mulan cuts her
own throw over her father's grave and
this is just one of many versions of
mulan's Story one that demonstrates just
how much a story can change over the
course of history
The Princess and the Frog is unique
among Disney movies and that it has a
very specific real world setting New
Orleans in 1928. granted there are a few
Liberties taken here and there but by
and large Tiana lives in the world as we
know it World War one took her father
from her so-called sugar Barons and
cotton Kings dominate the Louisiana she
lives in and businessmen dismiss her
Ambitions for regrettably predictable
reasons a little woman of your
background would have had a hands full
trying to run a big business like that
of course Tiana ends up proving that
naysayers wrong best of all even her
success is rooted in history Tiana was
inspired by Leah Chase a legendary Chef
known as the queen of Creole Cuisine her
restaurant dookie Chase is an American
Landmark having become a gathering place
for the members of the Civil Rights
Movement a dazzling art gallery and of
course a celebrated Beacon of Creole
cooking dookie Chase has served leaders
and luminaries ranging from Barack Obama
to Ray Charles who even mentions the
restaurant in early morning blues Chase
who was delighted to serve as the
inspiration for Tiana passed away in
2019 at the age of 96. her Legacy lives
on and her restaurant her cooking and of
course the Princess and the Frog
what is a Disney princess well that's
easy it's a princess from a Disney movie
right and sure things can get a little
fuzzy okay first I'm princess
same difference no if you wear a dress
and you have an animal sidekick you're a
princess but the definition generally
holds then again what about Mulan as a
commoner albeit one of great distinction
Mulan isn't a princess even by the most
generous definition of the word moreover
neither Elsa nor Anna from Frozen are
considered official Disney princesses
even if you allow for Elsa's exclusion
given the fact that she is a queen that
doesn't explain why Anna wasn't
considered one when the first movie came
out in reality what makes a Disney
princess is a question with no real
answer and the literal definition of a
princess has never really mattered much
as a long time Disney fans might recall
Mulan has been part of the line from the
very beginning as was Tinkerbell until
she was removed to lead the Disney
Fairies franchise even Anna and Elsa's
position has also grown mercury in
recent years their inclusion in Ralph
breaks the internet's princess-centric
scenes can be taken as evidence that
they are now considered Disney
princesses yet they remain absent from
the official Disney princess website so
what gives what actually makes a Disney
princess for now the answer remains a
mystery
believe it or not some people weren't
exactly keen on the idea of a line of
Disney Princesses Roy E Disney Walt
Disney's nephew and a long time
executive at the company was among the
most outspoken critics of the franchise
he believed that bringing the princesses
together under one brand would basically
destroy the value of their movies this
had been the prevailing wisdom for years
too Once Upon a Time an Ariel doll would
have been very clearly marketed as a
Little Mermaid while a Jasmine doll
would have been marketed as an aladdin
toy Disney and those of like Minds
believed that the movies were the core
of the company and shouldn't be messed
with under any circumstance obviously
the Disney Princess idea prevailed and
went on to earn the company billions of
dollars but the critics managed to win a
few concessions for example each
princess is distinguished by a signature
color meaning that Aurora's infamously
color changing dress was made to settle
on Pink So as not to compete with
Cinderella strangest of all however it
was agreed that the princess should
never make eye contact whether they
appeared together on backpacks cereal
boxes and posters they were to give no
indication that they existed on the same
plane as the princess beside them these
days however you've got to assume that
this rule is no longer strictly observed
given well this do you have daddy issues
I don't even have a mom neither do we
picture this a band of Heroes from a
range of Disney movies gathered together
to fight evil in one Epic Blockbuster
movie sure your mind might go to these
guys but forget about them for a minute
what about a movie that brings together
every Disney princess of course an idea
like that would have seemed absurd once
but in the era of the Cinematic Universe
all things are possible as Ralph breaks
the internet proved back in 2018 though
the Disney Princesses take up little of
Ralph's run time they made a huge impact
on the discourse surrounding the movie
multiple news items dissecting
discussing and celebrating the scene
sprung up in the movie's way awake a
boatload of merchandise of the
princesses and their loungewear was
released and fan speculation over a pan
princess movie began in Earnest and
these aren't just idle fan rumors either
Ralph directors Phil Johnston and Rich
Moore have considered the possibility
themselves in an interview with the AV
club Moore called it quote an idea worth
exploring revealing that no matter where
the movie played fans were off the
charts about the princess scene though
they noted that they have no idea if
this is an idea that Disney is
considering the fact that it was brought
up at all shows that there is some
serious creative interest about a Disney
princess crossover movie
the world of Disney princess merchandise
is vast and ever expanding even the
luckiest kid in the world couldn't hope
to own every single princess branded
item pushed out into the marketplace and
that's only counting the stuff
explicitly meant for kids while most
Disney princess merch is indeed for
children there is a whole range of
products featuring Disney princesses
that squarely aimed at grown-ups
considering tying the knot you can now
put a Disney princess engagement ring on
it then walk down the aisle in a Disney
princess wedding dress want to keep the
Disney Spirit Alive as you eat you can
buy a 16 piece dinnerware set inspired
by your heroine of Joyce looking to
primp in princess style then drop a few
hundred bucks on some Disney princess
Brandon makeup you can even liven up
boring grown-up tasks like meal planning
and bill payment with the official
Disney princess planner you can't say
they don't go all out can you ideally a
trip to a Disney park should feel
effortlessly magical and the passion
these Parks Inspire and the legions of
devotees proves that most of the time
Disney just about pulls it off but when
it comes to hanging out with the
princesses themselves things start
feeling a lot less effortless now
meeting the princesses is certainly
possible they're a place all over the
park and are usually available for
photos autographs and tearful
confessions of childhood love but then
there are the rarer events like
Cinderella's Royal table a luxurious
meal at Cinderella's castle that
features appearances from the princesses
themselves these events are a whole lot
harder to attend and thousands of post
articles and blogs exist that aim to
help Park goers Wrangle a reservation
according to one Intrepid mom
Cinderella's Royal table requires an
aspiring dinner guest call exactly 180
days prior to the desired date at
precisely 7am not even that is foolproof
however and some gurus suggest making
multiple reservations less one time
become untenable this sort of
reservation hoarding is controversial to
say the least but when it comes to
making the match happens for little ones
most parents are willing to play a
little dirty